hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve partition
equal subset sum so this is a pretty
interesting problem so we're given a
non-empty array of nums containing
only positive integers we want to know
if the array can be partitioned into two
different subsets such that the sum of
each of the subsets
is exactly equal notice how that's
basically saying
if we can take one subset of the array
which is going to equal
half of the sum of the entire array
right because
if we partition it into two equal halves
right let's say the total sum was 22
if we partitioned it into equal halves
then each of the halves would be exactly
11 right
aka one of the partitions is going to be
half that of the total sum
so for example in this problem the sum
is exactly 22. so we want to know can we
get a partition or can we get a
subset of this array basically we can
choose
any of the values and can we get a
subset such that it sums
up to 11. in this case the answer is yes
it's true because we can take you know
the single 11 that sums up to 11 right
and obviously if there's one way to get
half of the
sum of the total array then the
remaining elements are going to
basically equal 11 as well right so you
can see that 1
plus 5 plus another 5 is going to be
equal to 11 right basically these are
the two partitions
so as with many problems let's just try
to figure out what the brute force
solution would be so basically let's
start at the first
element right and for every single
element that we visit we have two
choices right we can either include this
in our sum
or we cannot include it in our sum and
we want to basically determine
every single sum that we can make with
any single subset from this given array
and we want to know does that sum
ever equal 11 because 11 is our target
right if we sum this
up divide it by 2 we get 11. so we want
to know if that's
possible so let's brute force it right
so the first choice we can either choose
a
1 or choose nothing right basically
skipping that so either our sum will be
1 or our sum will be zero because
initially our sum
is zero so the next value is five right
so basically for each of these
uh paths we can choose five or not
choose five if we do choose five here
we'll get a six if we don't we'll
stay at one otherwise on this path if we
choose the five we'll get a five
because we started at zero so if we skip
the five we'll stay at zero
next we get a we get an 11 so basically
continuing that right so i don't know if
i'm going to have enough room for this
okay
11 plus 6 is going to give us 17 on this
path
clearly we went over so we would
probably not want to continue down this
path
but over here if we skip the 11 we'll
get a 6 still
if we take 11 here we're going to get 12
if
we skip it we'll get one and etc etc
we'll get 16 here skip we'll get five
if we take 11 here we'll get 11 skip get
zero but clearly we found our target
that we were looking for we
we don't really have to continue anymore
right so basically we can skip this last
element
we found our target we're gonna return
true and we're gonna go
back up so as you can tell since every
level of our decision tree we're having
two choices right and what's the height
of this decision tree gonna be basically
for every single element
right we're going to have a decision so
let's say the input size of the array is
n so basically our time complexity is
going to be 2 to the power of
n if we do a brute force method so let's
go back to the first step
basically the first element that we were
at and let's see if there's any repeated
work that we can cut down on
so initially our index or our eye
pointer is at the first element right
so basically we're at the beginning of
the array we can go down the entire
array we can choose any elements from
here but and we want to know can we
sum up to the target 11. now once we
take our two paths right
we're basically going to say i is now
going to be shifted to the next element
five right
and we had two choices we could have
either chosen the one or we could have
skipped the one
but clearly now we have a new sub
problem
we already have a one so from the
perspective of this decision
we're not looking for a target of 11
anymore right we're looking for a target
of 10. we're looking for a target of 10
and not
only that but our initially our eye
pointer was here meaning we could have
we could have done the entire array but
now our eye pointer is over here
so we're not even looking at the entire
array anymore we're looking at a
subarray basically the remaining
elements of the array
minus this first one so if we were to
cache this
our new sub problem would be target of
10 that we're trying to solve and i
is not at zero anymore index is at
one similarly over here we can see since
we're at zero the target is still 11
right we are trying to sum up
all the way to 11 but the index that
we're starting at
in this case as well is one now right
because
we basically said we were skipping this
element down this path right so now we
want to know is there a way
that we can sum up to 11 basically just
from this subarray right
and every time we made a decision we
would continue to update these values
target and i right so
as you can see what are the dimensions
of our cache going to be if these are
the two
variables of our cache what are the
dimensions going to be well clearly
clearly i could be
any value in the input array so the
dimensions of our cache are going to be
n where basically n is the size of the
input array right because i could be at
any value from zero to
n minus one and what about the target
well the target is basically the sum of
the entire array divided by two right so
basically
sum of nums divided by two
or you know the constants usually don't
matter in time complexity so basically
this is going to be
the big o time complexity now this is
technically
better than 2 to the power of n
because they do give us a pretty good
limitation like the values in this input
array are usually going to be i think
less than or equal to 200. now if they
were really big like if this could have
been a million
clearly that would not be very efficient
because our sum could have potentially
been
super large but this is basically the
best way that we can optimize it
so basically if we did a depth-first
search solution with a
cache like a backtracking solution with
a cache this would be the time
complexity and this would also be the
memory complexity because this would be
the dimensions of our cache
but it's actually possible to improve
the memory complexity
a little bit with dynamic programming
and
the time complexity is mainly going to
stay the same as this but the overall
memory complexity can be improved and
let me show you why that's the case
so suppose we were starting at this
first value right and let's say we
already knew all the possible sums that
any given subset from the remainder of
this
array like basically what we could do is
say
for every single one of those sums we we
would add
one to it right so for every t let's
just call it t for now
in that subarray we're going to be
basically be checking two things right
either
if t is equal to target right like some
possible sum from this sub rate totaled
up to the target then we would return
true right
every possible sum that we could create
from any subset in this subarray
and if it total basically that that's
what t would be and if that t
happened to be equal to the target
target 11 then we would return true
right
or if we took every single sum we could
create from the subarray
and added one to it basically one
because that's the only value
left over here right one plus t
equal to target if that was also equal
to 11
then we would return true as well right
so basically this is the recurrence
relation that i'm trying to show you
and so this is basically the idea we're
gonna use for the bottom up solution so
instead of starting here we're gonna
work our way backwards so we're gonna
start here so
and this is very simple right so how
many possible sums
could we create from this sub array well
there's only one value here right we
either take it or we don't so
the amount of sums we can create is
going to be zero
or five and what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna be storing these values in a
set so let's say this is our set so so
far we have zero and
five next what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
i'm gonna go to 11
right we're going to work our way
backwards i'm going to start at 11
and i'm going to iterate through every
single one of these and i'm basically
going to
add 11 to them right so for 0 let's add
11 to it that's going to be 11 i'm going
to add that to our set
let's look at 5 that's going to be 11.
i'm going to add that
11 plus 5 is 16. i'm going to add that
to our set right clearly we can see we
already
found the target value so we could
return but let's just keep going to see
all the possible targets we could create
with this input array
so we we were done visiting 11. now
let's go to five right so basically
we're going to iterate through every
single one of these
add 5 to them and then see if that's a
new value if it's already a value that
exists
then we wouldn't do anything like in
this case we can see see 5
plus 0 is just going to be five right so
i'm not going to add a second
five to this because we already have a
five this is a set it's gonna
want only unique values so we're not
gonna end up adding a second five
but if we add five plus five that's
gonna be a ten if we add five plus 11
that's going to be a 16. we already have
a 16. if we add 5 plus 16 that's going
to be 21.
and basically i'm going to do the exact
same thing with one so
you know we would add a 1 here we'd add
a 6
5 plus 1 is six one plus eleven
is twelve one plus sixteen is
seventeen and one plus ten is eleven we
already have
eleven one plus twenty one is twenty two
so basically
this is the entire list of sums we could
possibly create
from our given input array as long as
this
set contains 11 we return true if it
doesn't contain 11
that means it's impossible to sum up to
this target
so we would return false now i think in
practice the size of the set is probably
going to be about the same size as the
cache that we would use in the
memoization
technique but technically the size of
this
this cache is going to be limited to the
size of the target which is basically
uh limited by the sum of the nums input
array so this is going to be the memory
complexity in this case
technically the time complexity is going
to be the same
but i think this this solution is
definitely easier to code
it's just a little bit tricky to
actually arrive to the solution
i think going through the brute force to
the caching
to the dynamic programming solution is
the best thought process to arrive
to this optimal solution so now let's
jump into the code
so one thing i didn't mention is that if
the sum
of our input array is odd then it's
obviously going to be impossible to
partition it into an equal half right so
basically if the sum
of this modded by two is one then we're
going to return
false also i'm going to have a dp set as
i mentioned because this is going to be
the most optimal solution
to the dp set i'm just going to add a
base case of zero basically
we're guaranteed that we can add up to a
sum of zero right if we just don't
choose any elements from the input array
nums
and the target that we're trying to sum
up to is of course the sum
of nums divided by two
so with that being said let's iterate
through every single value
in nums in reverse order you could do it
in regular order but i'm just gonna do
reverse order because i'm used to it so
so we're gonna go through every target
or every total value that's already
in our dp set for every t and dp
and what we want to do is 2dp add
a value right we basically want to add t
plus nums of i right because i is the
current index that we're at
we want to add it for every single t
that's already in dp we want to add
numbers of i to it right but we can't
update this dp set while we're iterating
through it so what i'm going to do is
create a new dp
set basically next dp it's going to be
the dp set that we iterate through over
the
you know the next time we execute the
loop so instead of adding to dp what i'm
going to do is add to next
dp but we also don't want to lose all
the original values that are
in dp so what i'm also going to do is to
next
dp i'm going to add the t value
as well whatever the t value happened to
be now if i really wanted to i could
probably skip this line if i just took
dp and
cloned it and then set that to next dp
but
you know whatever you prefer basically
what i'm doing is taking
i'm setting next dp i'm taking every
value in dp adding it to next dp
and also adding this t plus nums of i
to nextdp and once this loop is done
executing we're basically going to
update
reassign dp to the next dp
set and this is going to keep executing
it's going to keep executing i is going
to start at the end it's gonna
it's gonna go all the way to zero so
then we're gonna have gone through every
single one
and at the end we can return true if and
only if the target happens to exist
in dp else we have to return false
and yeah so this is the entire code and
it runs
fairly efficiently so this is about 50
now i think it would probably be a
little bit faster if you know the first
time we find the target value if we just
returned it
actually let me just you know you can
probably stop watching at this point
that was the entire solution but let me
just see if this actually does speed it
up so let's say
if i happens to be equal to the target
we can immediately return true
let me see if that does speed it up okay
so that actually did so it's about
twice as fast i think the old one was 14
milliseconds so this is 600 milliseconds
so this might be an optimization that
your interviewer would like
but the overall time complexity is still
the same but i hope that this was
helpful
if it was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot and i'll
hopefully
see you pretty soon thanks for watching